[Music]
hello everyone
and welcome back to chess openings
explained
tonight once and for all i am beginning
the
final say the final authority on the f3
nimzo uh this is going to be a series
where i go directly through
all of the relevant variations in the f3
nimzo indian
and give you guys a working knowledge of
how to play the opening
and the goal as with the night of series
is that by the end of it you're
confident enough to just pull it out
uh at notice and play it in your real
over the board games
um and i have taught some lectures uh
featuring the f3 nimzo or revolving
around the f3 nimzo
but as i said this video series is going
to be the final authority on it
um i am hopefully going to be
linking a lead chess study with all the
lines and all of the variations
that we go over each monday night
in the youtube description so if you do
want to have sort of a record of these
lines that's something that a lot of
people requested during the night of
series
they are going to be available in that
youtube description each week
and then give me some feedback on this
but i was toying around with the idea
of putting in a little extra work and
maybe making a chessable repertoire i
know that's all the rage these days
let me know what you guys think in the
comments and in the chat here and we'll
uh
we'll we'll see we'll see if i actually
get around to it but
for this lecture i wanted to start off
with
uh not the main line at the top level
but by far the most common line at the
club level the amateur level
and it's a really interesting thing to
see the the huge
disparity between uh what the top
players are playing
and what the the class level players are
playing because
the top level players they sort of avoid
this line like the plague
they sort of realize that hey this stuff
is really difficult to play for black
if if you go into these variations and
white might just be getting a distinct
opening advantage
so this is why i like the f3 nimzo so
much it has
definitely scored me more you know
quote-unquote free wins
in my tournament history than any other
opening because so many
uh class level players are just playing
into this line that is very very very
difficult for black
and so to start with we are going to get
to some real chess games by some high
level players
but i wanted to give you a quick four
games that i played in the past year all
of these are our 2019
and onwards um four games where i was
just
strictly winning by move 25 and in most
of them i used very little time on my
clock because it's all moves that i had
played
you know 100 times before this is just
how everybody is losing to the f3 nimzo
to start off with
i want to show you this game that i
played against derek higgins which by
the way
these chess players are are you know not
not passers by any means these were all
uh
around the 2000 level a little bit
higher in most cases
and this is just how all of my games are
going right so to start with
we have d4 knight f6 c4
e6 knight c3 bishop b4 and the
you know denoting move of the opening
the f3 nimzo of course
happens by white playing the move f3 and
we're going to get into all the nitty
gritty here
but basically what i've found is class
level players
aren't totally prepared to be meeting
this move f3 it's not the most common
variation i wouldn't call it a sideline
by any means it's
it's definitely main main theory but
um players with the black pieces usually
i think are skipping over this variation
and what happens when a player with the
black pieces in the nimzo indian
sort of gets a little bit lost and
doesn't know what they're doing well
they all play the move d5 which is fair
enough d5 is a perfectly reasonable move
right
you know when in doubt control the
center revert back to opening principles
uh and probably when most of the the
players with the black pieces are making
their names
indian repertoire they see f3 and they
say okay apparently this d5 move is fine
and then i just develop my pieces and
and life is good but life is not good
so to start with we're going to play the
move a3 and there is a bishop e7 line
that we're going to get to
but we're going to focus on bishop take
c3 today b takes c3
and then there are two moves here that
get played most often there's
c5 and there's castles and those are the
two that we're going to look at
and they have largely the same idea so
in this game derek decided to castle
white should now fix the double pawns
and go e3
and now white's simple idea is to play
bishop d3
knight d2 to g3 and at some moment push
e4
and breakthrough in the center and this
simple idea
is actually so powerful that this is how
i'm scoring
all of these free wins in the f3 nemzo
i'm getting this exact position
over and over and over again players
with the black pieces continue
to play into this position in this very
simplistic plan where you develop the
bishop
develop the knight and push e4 is just
just scoring free wins
and here's how black played in the game
rookie 8
bishop d3 c5 attacking the center this
is the correct idea
knight e2 and then anybody's who's
anybody
is playing b6 and bishop a6 to get rid
of this powerful bishop and we're going
to look at this
that's what i like to call the main line
and this e takes d5 variation
when black goes b6 and bishop a6 to get
rid of the bishop
but over the board i have very very
rarely faced this
so in the game knight c6 was played and
i think this is a little bit of a
misstep
because black can no longer get rid of
this light squared bishop
so just for the sake of example i'm
going to go through these pretty quickly
i castled black played c4 which we'll
see is a mistake because it gives up
pressure on the d4
pawn the bishop simply retreats now b6
was played
like i said knight g3 white's moves are
all very very simple we're controlling
the e4 push
black played h6 e4
uh black was now powerless to stop this
move there's just no way to prevent
white from getting e4
d takes e takes bishop g4 was played
queen e1
and then my opponent was so terrified of
my attack that they sacrificed a piece
on d4 and went on to lose very
very quickly just centralizing the
pieces
rook takes f6 is always a good sacrifice
in these lines
knight h5 my opponent didn't even take
on f6
and here my opponent resigned on move
25.
let's jump into a second game let's see
how this one went this time i was
playing against griffin thomas mcconnell
another 2070 or so rated player of
course we start with the f3 nimzo
black plays d5 a3 takes takes in this
game my opponent played b6 which is a
little bit of a strange move order but
nothing too crazy
take on d5 e3 notice how i'm playing the
exact same moves as last game
queen e7 in this case bishop d3 simple
enough queen e7 a very strange move by
the way
uh bishop b7 same moves as always 92
castles castles knight g3 black adopts a
totally different and wild setup but it
just doesn't matter in this case
rookie 8 was played in the game and now
i bring in a second rook to support the
e4 push
and now once again by move 15 black is
powerless to stop e4
we crash through in the center and once
again
rook takes f6 is actually the tactic
that is ending the game
uh with my opponent resigning here on
move 23.
let's look at a third game this time i'm
playing ryan ambergee a 1998 rita player
he actually got above 2 000
in this tournament so congrats to him on
that
and once again uh the f3 nimzo we still
see black playing d5
we see this trade e3 this time
black made a little bit of a bigger
effort to get rid of the bishop and went
back to g6
the bishops get traded off the board and
then once again knight b to d7 is played
by black which is not
quite accurate again we're gonna get
into the details a little bit later
castles once again uh i activate the
rook along the second rank
break through in the center and just
push the pawns forward
right that's it's as simple as that you
push the pawns forward
and checkmate the king and here my
opponent resigns
this time he survived a little bit
longer making it all the way to move 31
before giving up the game all right all
right i promise i'm almost done
but one more example of this just to
really hit home the point
that this is the line that people are
playing over the board
and they're not passers they're 2 000
level players they are very
experienced tournament players with you
know
solid you know grounded opening
repertoires like they they know what
they're doing in the opening these these
guys
you know they're they're not bad chess
players by any means but they're just so
unprepared for this f3 nimzo indian and
these are the games that you guys are
going to be getting
most of the time right most of the time
one more game one more game this time i
was against luke you
again the f3 nimzo this time black
doesn't even play d5 luke just captured
on c3
unprovoked which of course in the main
line i'm playing a3 to provoke this move
so this just wastes time then d5
transposing into positions that we know
and here black doesn't even get to
castle i played bishop a3
and this is just so so sad and once
again
by move 25 the game is is ending the
same moves we've seen a thousand times
before now
castles e4 and once again
rook takes f6 and once again the game is
ending
shortly after with just a devastating
attack on the king's side
queen h6 rook g7 and this game is is
over
check and mate on move 28.
so i know that's kind of a long
introduction there but i just wanted to
show you
how often i'm getting these positions
and how badly all of my opponents are
are playing them now that's not to say
i've won every game of my life in the f3
nimzo i have played some super strong
players
and lost to them in various uh various
other lines
but this by far is the most common move
that i'm facing
and if you do a quick look in the lead
chess database
in this position well sorry we'll get
back to the normal stuff d5
in this position is very very common
a3 takes takes um
c5 c takes d5 and in the masters
database
e takes d5 achieving the positions that
we we're actually looking at today
this has only been played a little under
500 times
right a little under 500 times for
the thousands and thousands of games in
the f3 nimzo variation so
by any stretch of the imagination e
takes d5 here
is very much a sideline at the top level
this is a sideline this is not what the
top level guys are playing against
the f3 nimzo you know on a daily basis
however if you flip over to
the leachate database
c takes d5 e takes d5 here has been
played
over three thousand times and here
castles
has been played over twelve thousand
times when of course after c takes d5 e
takes d5 is the only
uh only move actually for black here
over 8 000 times
by far the most popular move and this is
by far
what most people are doing against the
f3 nimzo indian
on the lead chess database and uh you
know
and from my anecdotal experience over
the board as well this is what i'm
facing this d5 variation so
if you go home and you look at a
database yourself and you say
why is he spending so much time on this
d5 line like the top level players they
just don't do this well it's because
speaking from experience and speaking
from the numbers on lead chess
this is what your average chess player
is playing against the f3 nimzo indian
so with all of that out of the way and
with my you know short little brag
session of my my four free wins in in
the past year
let's take a look at some real chess
players so
uh the first game i want to go over is a
game between liam le quang
and alex alexandrov who is
a very strong grandmaster over 25 70
at the time of this game but of course
uh liam le quang
is or liam kwang lay liam lay we'll call
him
i always mess up the order of his name
uh apologies to him
uh he's he's you know a super grand
master over 2700
you know world rapid champion at some
point this guy is is ridiculous so let's
see how this game goes
uh we got to the f3 nimzo via slightly
strange move order in this case with c4
e6 knight c3 d5
d4 bishop b3
a3 takes takes
uh c5 e3 knight f6
c takes e takes but we we are getting
there eventually
so the thing i wanted to highlight is
not so much this this opening move order
but perhaps it does play a role as to
why we actually saw this being played
in this game because it's almost as if
black
is only playing this position because he
got move order tricked by by liam lay
right that's how much these people are
avoiding this line in the f3 nimzo
they're like yeah okay i got tricked
into this so now i have to play it
that's that's where they're at
just just for reference the game
continued though with bishop d3
kingside castles knight e2 these moves
should look very familiar
b6 so we do in fact see
c black going for this bishop trade
castles
bishop a6 f3 take on d3
take on d3 and now i want to pause here
to talk about the actual ideas
in this variation so hopefully it's
apparent
to many of you why it's good for black
to trade off these light squared bishops
but just in case it's not i want to just
highlight here
imagine if you play the move knight c6
instead
then this bishop isn't going to have a
home well this bishop is just
absolutely dominating the board and
hopefully by
the four games i showed at the start you
can see that this bishop is going to be
a powerful attacking piece
once the center of the board opens up
and white is opening up this f-file
pushing these pawns in the center this
bishop is just going to be a powerhouse
of the piece
that being said there is one idea with
the line of knight c6 that i want to get
to but i'm going to
stick with this line of b6 and bishop a6
first
so castles bishop a6 f3 and by the way
you know of course f3 would have been
played much much earlier in
in the case of the f3 nimzo but this
position is
is actually identical to the main line
of this variation
in in the actual f3 nimso so don't worry
too much about that move order there
basically all you need to know you go f3
you go bishop d3 you go
92 you castle and you're gonna get this
this exact position
and as i said this is what i call the
main line
so what are the ideas here for black why
is black playing like this
why is black keeping this pawn on c5
well
the fact of the matter is this move f3
is good enough at controlling the e4
square
that black is just never going to be
able to stop the move e4
by controlling it and you only need to
look at that game i had against griffin
thomas mcconnell
to really see that the guy played bishop
b7 played queen e7 played rookie eight
and i was still able to play e4 right
you just can't
get enough firepower on the e4 square to
stop that move forever
so what does this mean for black does
this mean you just have to give
up and allow white to play e4 well not
necessarily
black has a really good idea to actually
balance the idea of e4 by pressuring the
d4 pawn
not the e4 square but the d4 pawn now
how does that make any sense
well as soon as white plays e4 black is
going to be able to
open the d file with d takes e and then
all of a sudden the pressure on the d
pawn is going to be greatly enhanced
by black's queen on the d file as well
as the c
pawn and so the real trouble for white
in this variation
often isn't getting the move e4 n
getting e4
in on the e4 square is very very easy
with this pawn on f3
but what's not easy is making sure
you're also controlling d4 enough
to not just be losing a pawn at the end
of the variation
so black is leaving this pawn on c5 and
purposefully
not bringing it to the c4 square because
black is relying
on this pressure on the d4 pawn to keep
this e4 id
idea at bay of course though
this is a half open file so in the game
black first
play first plays rookie 8 we see knight
g3
again the very natural idea from white
knight e2 to g3
controls the e4 square and helps to
facilitate this break
and then knight c6 and black is now
controlling the d4 upon pawn in order to
stop this break
of e4 so that being said
what should white do in response to this
do you think i'm going to turn it over
to the chat room i did a lot of talking
at the top of the hour
but if you guys have been following uh
so far hopefully you're starting to to
get a good feel
for this this sort of main position
so with the white pieces here black has
put up
a lot more resistance than the first
four opponents that i showed
that that were all from my personal
games so with this in mind
how do we continue black has gotten rid
of our our strong bishop and is
countering our idea of e4
by putting a ton of pressure on the d4
pawn
so yeah there seems to be a few
conflicting ideas
in the chat so this idea of rook a2 to
e2 you guys probably briefly saw
in those first games that i was showing
and this is often a really great
maneuver
for white however it's not the most
relevant
thing to the position right now usually
you go rook
a2 and over to e2 when this first rank
is a little bit more clogged up when
you're not so able
to uh to just move this rook to the the
e file
via via the first rank right in this
case our queen has been drawn to the d3
square by the trait of these bishops
and with our next move which is another
idea in the chat bishop b2
the first rank is now totally clear for
this rook to come into the center of the
board
now why are we playing bishop b2 and not
bishop d2
well of course we are trying to control
the d4
pawn we're not so interested in
controlling the e4 square
black is already sort of giving up
control over this square
wow now the thing that we need to
control is the d4 pawn
to ensure that we can play e4 because
what happens if we play e4 directly
well black's idea is in fact working
here because we are just one piece short
on the d4 square and black would be
winning a pawn
so the slightly counter-intuitive bishop
b2
putting this bishop on a very very close
diagonal is
actually the right idea in this case
and now in this game black makes a
pretty committal decision
that i want to talk about so black
is always always always facing this very
difficult decision
of whether or not to play the move pawn
on c5
down to c4 why is this such a difficult
decision
for black to face well
because if you don't play pawn to c4
it's actually a little bit
unclear where black is actually finding
active play
in the position right what is black's
active plan here aside from sort of
holding everything together
and waiting for white to play the move
e4 breaking open the position it's it's
not so clear
but what does c4 allow black to do
well once this queen moves out of the
way black has a very active plan
of going a5 and let's say white plays
some bad moves and b4
right and now with the open a file
this is where black's source of counter
play is going to be coming from
and this is the main idea of playing the
pawn out to uh to c4
rather than leaving it on c5 and
in the game this is the type of stuff
that black actually went for
black actually does play c4 in this case
the second
uh alexandrov saw this bishop come to b2
he said no way am i opening this
diagonal lever i'm going to go c4
my pressure on the d4 pawn has already
been nullified by this bishop being here
so i have no reason to to leave this
pawn on c5 anymore
and it goes c4 and that is the downside
to playing c4 you give up
any and all pressure on the d4 pawn and
so c4
is essentially conceding the move e3 e4
to white
what does this mean well it means that
black is going to have
a very short clock to get this counter
play on the queen side going
before white is able to break in the
center
and by the way i don't know if you've
ever heard this principle in chess
but what's the best way to encounter an
attack on the flank
well it's with an attack in the center
and my experience has been
that this attack in the center is almost
always more relevant
more forcing more urgent than blacks
play on the queen side of the board
but let's take a brief look at what
happens if black
is a little bit more resilient and says
no i'm not playing c4 i'm leaving this
pressure here
and plays a move like rook c8 well white
really has
two different options here you can play
rook ade1
but i think just e4 directly is fine
oftentimes it's not the most important
thing if you actually prepare this move
further with a move like rook a to e1
if you can play e4 and you're not
hanging any pawns then it's
more often than not just just a good
move and that is actually the case here
so black's best try is to open things up
by
capturing and capturing again
and then there's an interesting little
tactic of 95 taking advantage of this
pin
but after the move queen to e2 knight to
c4
already here white is is significantly
better um it's at least
plus one and uh it's probably going to
be more than that
within within the next few moves for
example
um just one way to play would be e5
let's say black wants to take this
bishop before it's too late
knight d5 knight e4 um or sorry rather
knight f5 is probably a bit better and
it's very very clear
that white is just taking over in the
center of the board
so once again though black is sort of
left with no active play
after rook to c8 so if you even want to
you can just play something like rook a
to e1
and wait one more time turn for this
move e4
and this is also going to be perfectly
fine fine for white and in fact i think
white does just have a distinct
advantage in the position
so maybe then uh knight a5 is a good try
for uh for black and once again knight
a5
allows white to play e4 without hanging
upon and white is perfectly justified in
doing so here
knight c4 now we can just bring the
bishop back to c1
this knight is no longer pressuring d4
so black can no longer win the pawn
and once again you're going to see
things open up
oh well sorry not like that rook c8 for
example
e5 knight d7 f4
and once again now this position is is
pretty close to plus two for white
white is just completely winning in this
position with this idea of pushing in
the center
and pushing this f pawn up the board to
uh to checkmate black
so with all of that in mind i think
while
many many times i've been very very
critical of the move c4
i think this is black's best chance in
this case black needs to get this active
counter play
on the queen's side and it sort of
doesn't matter if the pawn's on c5
anymore
why doesn't it matter because white is
defending the d4 pawn enough already
right this pressure on d4 is sort of
meaningless if white can play e4
anyways so all of that is to say this is
one of the very rare circumstances where
i do think c4 is the best
that black can do that being said how
should white continue
well this queen can either go to d2 or
e2 it's important that it stays in
contact with the e3 pawn here
don't want to hang that guy in the game
liam lay
played the move queen to e2
and black comes up with an interesting
idea of h5 and this is a really really
useful idea for black
uh to remember in this variation the
point of
h5 is the pretty interesting h4
which highlights the fact that this
knight just doesn't have very many
squares to go to g3 is sort of
the optimal square for it and uh h4 is
going to make that piece
move again and now liam lee comes up
with
a really interesting move here so see
what you think
white can do in this position chat room
what do you think here
what do you think
uh and someone in the chat said now
white's bishop is is terrible
um i yeah i guess you're you're talking
about this specific position yeah
we'll see if this bishop is terrible
forever we'll see if it's terrible
forever
we shall see
so everybody in the chat is suggesting
the move h4 which is not actually my
favorite move
uh this pawn is just a little bit too
weak white can't really hold on to
the h4 square and uh i think black is
just winning a pawn here like you you
can't defend this
it's actually indefensible very
difficult stuff
so the idea um liam lay comes up with
is just a very simple improving move
this queen
is opposite of rook and pretty much
regardless of where this queen went
there's a better square for it than e2
or d2
and that square is f2 with the queen on
f2
white is immediately applying pressure
to the f7 pawn
sort of preparing once again for the
opening of
the e file and of course stepping out of
this pin
and furthermore attacking the pawn on h4
if black were to move it there now black
continued the game with b5
once again black needs to get this
active counter play going on the queen
side rather quickly white plays the
simple rook a to e1
ready to uh to push to e4 and now black
goes for this move
of h4 perhaps black's best try
would have been just to go a5 directly
but now
white is fully prepared for this move of
e4
and once again white's playing the
center is just going to be more powerful
more direct than black's play on the
queen side e4
e5 is coming and after that f4 f5 is
coming
and then after that checkmate is is
coming very difficult to stop these
ideas
for for black just as an example let's
say some
you know simple moves get played f4
knight f8
f5 or k7 trying to defense or you know
we'll say b4 trying to counter attack
takes is is just immediately checkmate
it's it's just checkmate queen f7 knight
h5
it's just it's so so sad it's so so sad
here
it's all so so sad apparently this is
checkmate it doesn't matter
you guys i'm sure you believe me when we
get to that position
and that is checkmate so in the game
uh black goes for h4 which is an attempt
to further delay
the push to e4 but this push can only be
delayed for so long
um white's idea with the queen on f2 is
actually knight f5 here
and this is an idea that was sort of new
to me when i was prepping for this
lecture
this idea of just directly attacking the
h4 pawn with knight f5 and queen f2
in general there is a secondary idea
that
white can play if you go queen d2 for
example h5 rick ade 1
h4 oftentimes knight h1 is a good move
here for white
just rerouting the knight back to f2 so
i just wanted to introduce that this is
another idea in the position
as well bringing the knight to f2 but in
this case we see
liam lay go for this queen f2 knight f5
idea which does seem to be a good one
this pawn not so easy to defend in the
game black simply pushed it all the way
to h3
um and now liam lay keeps up the
pressure
with the interesting queen g3 just
pressuring this this king on the king's
side black plays g6 by the way i should
mention white is just winning
at this point it's once again plus two
in the position
all because of white's next move e4 this
is the break
in this f3 nimzo line that is just
always
coming with authority uh black did
capture on g2
white takes back with the queen we see
king h8
and now uh there were some missteps by
white knight back to g3
wasn't totally necessary for example
check and check was
was good but white never loses the
advantage we see the bishop come back to
c1
not such an awful bishop anymore bearing
down on the black king
queen h3 check is played bishop comes to
f4
and very much not such an awful bishop
anymore
king h1 was played black tries to trade
queens white declines
e5 and now pressure coming on the king's
side
and a devastating attack from uh liam
lay here
takes or g1 or g6 and black resigned
rather than wait for uh wait for queen
takes h7 check
in this case and yeah this is just
uh sort of a blowout win by liam like
but it's very very typical for from my
experience
in this f3 nimzo right even when black
does everything correctly as alexandrev
does in this case
even when they get rid of this powerful
bishop even when
they pressure the d4 pawn even when they
give up the pressure for counter play on
the queen side
it sort of doesn't matter it sort of
doesn't matter e4
is just always coming and it's always
good for
white um so questions on this game in
particular
and then i want to back up a little bit
and introduce one more idea for uh for
black that's useful to know about
the chat is saying i'm looking
aerodynamic with the haircut i
appreciate that
appreciate that did liam find this idea
over the board or was it prepped
i mean i have no idea i have no idea
it's been played a few
times but it's very it's a very
reasonable idea to see
over the board
all right let us move along then so uh
sticking
in in this game's variation i just
wanted to mention this idea here
uh in the game we saw b6 with the bishop
a6 idea
and i had been sort of touting knight c6
as a mistake because this
light squared bishop sort of has nowhere
to go that being said it has been played
numerous numerous times here in fact
it's the most popular move in this
position
but i just wanted to show what might
happen for example king side castles
rookie 8 f3 there is sort of one
idea here with this knight that actually
makes sense
and that is the idea of bishop d7
which looks a little bit odd but you
just get the bishop out of the way
and go for these knight a5 knight c4 id
diaz a little bit more quickly
what's the advantage to playing like
this over trading the bishops well i i
think somehow black is like a tempo
faster on the queen side
but i really don't have that much faith
in
these sorts of ideas from black that
being said there is one game i wanted to
go over here
and that in that game white was uh t
grand protrusion the world champion not
the cheater
and uh his opponent was uh
final answer this is all the way back in
1983
uh and that game went as follows white
plays
the normal moves uh black tries this
queen a5 idea
white stayed cool and just uh defended
this c pawn there oop sorry
oh sorry black tried queen a4
attacking some of these squares and to
be honest queen a4 doesn't make the most
sense to me but that was what was played
in the game rook b1
is usually a useful move for white uh
that's one idea to definitely remember
when black is going for this early type
of peace play on the queen side
rook b1 is almost always a useful move
why is that well you just don't want to
run into any knight b3 tactics
you also get a lot of pressure against
this b7 pawn and it sort of slows down
black's play pretty considerably and
we're going to see this rook b1 idea
up here a little bit later on as well
knight a5 was played in the game
bishop c2 uh and
one repetition and then who can guess
the best move for white
in this position i would ask you guys in
the chat room
see if you guys are starting to catch on
there's a question about why rook b1
over rook a2
in this case we don't need the extra
rook
to uh to play the best move which as
everybody in the chat is saying now e4
right this rook a2 to e2 idea is
something that you can do when black is
playing a bit more slowly
and trying to be more preventative of
the break e4
this is a great way to add another
defender to the e4 square
or if black is simply doing nothing and
you sort of have all the time in the
world again
it makes sense to bring the rook over to
the queen to the king side
or the center but in this case black is
not doing nothing black is playing
actively on the queen slide
so it makes more sense to bring the rook
to b1 where it can immediately be useful
since we don't actually need it in the
center but yes
black is wasting their time playing on
the queen side here so petrosian played
e4
takes takes uh takes
was played with seemingly a tactic that
wins a pawn
but white does have this move rook b4
here and this is good enough
to uh to win the game by the way if d
takes c3
queen g5 is now attacking two things at
the same time
and after queen c6 surprise it was
attacking
three things at the same time all along
and now white is just simply winning
um black tried sacrificing exchange
straight away
um protrosian didn't even immediately
take it
that nice little d5 sacrifice by the way
and then at the end of the day
this queen cannot capture due to
checkmate and this game ended very very
shortly
in petrossian's favor um so impressive
game there
i just wanted to highlight what it might
look like
if black tries this move knight c6
rather than this move b6 it has been
done a few times
but in my opinion it just doesn't make
sense the idea is to go for rapid play
on the queen side for black with stuff
like knight a5 and bringing in
bringing in the queen as well but white
is always faster in the center
with good play so when in doubt this
move rook b1
is occasionally nice to slow down the
play on the queen side a little bit
but always just be looking for
opportunities to play e4
because as soon as you play e4 and open
up the center all of a sudden the queen
slide doesn't matter
all the plays in the center all the play
is on black's king and that's
the sort of running theme here all right
so what does this mean
for this d5 e takes d5 variation of
the the nimzo indian is this just how
all the games go
is black just busted well yes and no
i do actually think white is getting a
nice advantage in these
the the main variations but black has a
couple more interesting ideas that you
definitely need to be aware of and be
ready for
uh if you're going to play this opening
yourself so i wanted to introduce those
sort of side variations you can call
them in this e takes d5 line
with the remainder of the lecture and i
do call them side variations
but uh this next game that we're going
to go over between
vidit and kramnik no pushover vladimir
kramnik but we'll see what happens
when he has his turn with the black side
of this this opening
we're going to see what happens here and
this game actually features a line
that made its way all the way into the
world championship
of chess notably it was not repeated
uh i wonder why but let's just take a
look at it here and we'll see if you
guys recognize
the the opening from any world champions
recently
it goes of course this time we play the
the normal move order for the f3 nimzo
we get d5 a3 bishop takes
b takes in this case kramnik goes c5 we
see c takes d5
and here actually the the most common
move is knight takes d5
and this is going to get its own lecture
because it's a very common
common idea for black but tonight we're
still focusing on e takes d5
e3 and now the idea
by kramnik in this game and by yes
spoilers magnus carlsen against vichyant
way back in 2013 the idea was to go for
an early early early early
pawn to c4 so of course i've talked
about the drawbacks of this move already
it allows white to play e4 a lot more
easily because it is not pressuring the
d4 pawn
and in all of the variations that i was
talking about i was saying e4 is never
really the problem for white the problem
is d4
in this case though black is playing c4
so early that white has not had the
opportunity
to develop the bishop on this b1 h7
diagonal
so there is a very distinct idea with
this move c4 it's not just coming out of
nowhere
and it's definitely something you need
to be ready for
so let's see how vidit chose to handle
it against kramnik
and then i'll also briefly mention when
we
divert away from from the world
championship game so
rather than trying to develop this
bishop out this way we see vitigo knight
e2
knight c6 this is still by the way uh
vichy versus magnus
and now g4 and this is the the nice idea
for white in response to this move c4
and why is this so good for white
well black is very distinctly closing
down the center with the move c4 black
now has very few opportunities to open
diagonals open files in front of
the center here and so white can be a
little bit more cavalier with these king
side pawns you can sort of just just go
a little bit crazy
the sacrifices on g4 are occasionally
interesting but are almost
always winning for white and principled
we we can kind of understand why that is
why the white king can always run this
way and then it runs into these two
blocked off files that can sort of never
be
never be ripped open and so this is why
the white king is a little bit
safe safer than you might expect even
after the crazy move g4
um now we see the move knight a5 by
kramnik
and also i think in the game of viciound
although maybe magnus carls
maybe magnus castled first i think we're
gonna transpose anyways
and knight a5 is the secondary idea with
this move c4
early control over the b3 square and
this is what kramnik goes for in the
game now we do see
vidit developing out with bishop to g2
this is the the secondary point of g4 by
the way you are taking space
on the the king side and you're also
getting this bishop
uh a square rather than the d3 square
which has been ripped
from our clutches knight b3 is the
follow-up idea
and then here uh in magnus carlsen
versus vishyanant
i think something like castles castles
was already included
but vishy chose to play rook a2 and i do
think despite it being far less common
rook b1
is just the better move in this case
why is rook b1 the better move in this
case
well it all comes down to this sort of
balance between rook a2 and rook b1
what's the point of rook a2 the point of
rook a2 is that we can swing the rook
across the board over to the king's side
over to the center to support our push
in the center to support our attack
what's the benefit of rook b1 the
benefit of rook b1
is slowing down black's counter play it
controls
b5 and b4 two squares which are
absolutely critical
for black's success on the queen side
black's idea with this early c4
is the same idea that we saw earlier
it's to eventually
be pushing a5 b5 and b4
going for these these uh space gains on
the queen side
opening files on the queen side and
finding counter play there
and in this case i think it's more
relevant to have this rook
stopping this queen side play than it is
to have the rook
with the mobility along the second rank
and we're going to see how it works
for vidit in this case we see castles
castles
and now black goes for b5 kramnik just
pushing
rather immediately in this case
and now wait to move what do you think
the best move is here
right to move chat what should we do
what should we do chatroom and there's
another question i'll go back to that in
a moment
and yeah this is sort of the secondary
mistake that i think vishy anand made
in his game against magnus carlson vichy
i believe
played the move knight g3 here and
it turns out that this is the most
immediate of all of the lines
that that we've looked at so far black
is immediately coming
on the queen side with this counter play
what does that mean well it means white
has to play with a little bit
more urgency than normal and so
moves like knight g3 would be great to
include we would love to include them
but actually white's best way
to uh to prove anything in this position
is to immediately play the move
e4 and that's what we see vita doing in
this game
strictly pawn to e4 um and by the way
vishy with the the slightly slower play
of knight g3 it's not as if he got a bad
position
uh he actually played a very long and
very double-edged game with magnus
and i think that game ended in disaster
for vichy
with a blunder way way late in the game
they played a very long and very
interesting game and it's one of my
favorite games
from that world championship match so if
you haven't seen it i would
definitely say go check it out but it's
not very relevant for our opening
discussion because vichy i believe
didn't seize every opportunity he had in
order to get some kind of advantage from
the opening
which vidit does in fact do here with
the move e4
so what's the downside to e4 well c
after takes takes
black by the way should always be
including knight takes c1
after e4 it would be a huge mistake for
black to allow this bishop to live and
develop out to one of these squares
so knight takes c1 played and then of
course we see
uh oh you've hung a g4 pawn and so in
fact
this is going to be a gambit now for um
for vedic here uh he's gambited the g4
upon
in return for these power this powerful
central duo
uh and it turns out you know if you just
do some
some math this isn't really how
evaluations work but in all the previous
positions
after white got this powerful central
duo it was something like plus one point
five plus two
and if you do plus one point five plus
two
minus one for the g pawn turns out
white's still out
coming out ahead right by the way
this line in particular really
highlights the fact that the rook is
well placed on b1
black is now going to have to spend time
defending this pawn
whereas if we had this rook in a2 it's
true that our knight would be defended
but black would be a little bit more
free to just push a5
b4 directly then with this rook on b1
um in the game we see knight f4 by vitit
no reason to come to g3 anymore we don't
need it to support e4 we've already
played e4
rook b8 now is the tempo lost by kramnik
h3 is played by vitit to force the
bishop back bishop comes all the way to
d7
and now the simple move e5 and this
knight has nowhere to go
and if you don't think this is good
enough compensation for a pawn
then i don't know what to tell you white
is completely dominating the center of
the board
this knight on e8 is very much a sad
piece for the moment
all of black's pieces are uncoordinated
and white has very good pressure
on the f-file as as well
let's see how the game actually
continued vidic continues activating his
pieces with queen e3
see rook b6 by vladimir kramnik and now
d5 is just absolutely
disastrous for uh for vladimir kramnik
white continues to push the central
majority
and this is vidit's winning plan in this
case
notably this is a little bit of a
different winning plan than what we saw
in a few of the previous games that i
showed in all those previous games
white was sort of breaking through on
the king's side with some sort of attack
but this winning plan is very useful to
know as well
white simply rolls forward with those
central pawns
and uses them to uh to sort of just take
away
every square in the black camp and
that's what vidit does
to great effect here kramnik now plays a
very very natural
move but it's also the losing move
knight c7
desperately trying to get this knight
back into the game but now after d6
knight e6 knight d5 hitting a rook or k6
and now rook f5 preparing to double
with pressure here knight e7 is coming
checkmate is coming ever it's just it's
over it's over
queen h4 played in the game rook b to f1
kramnik
grabs an a3 pawn hooray kramnik
queenside counter play we're all so
happy for you
we're all so happy for you we're all so
so happy
look at how happy we are oh my oh my
gosh are we happy
black resigns uh black resigns in this
case can't take the queen
rook f8 is is checkmate and despite
kramnik losing
you know with a full belly as yasser
says sometimes he got that a3 pawn
um he is still still losing um
this is just just checkmate once once
again
and uh this is just a very very dominant
idea
by vidit here so the idea that to
remember
uh you don't necessarily have to
remember all the the direct theory
but in almost every case this is what
white should be doing
against c4 what do i mean by that well
let's look
you go g4 you go bishop g2 you
if your rook is attacked you go rook b1
if your doesn't get attacked i don't
think you should spend the time
you castle and once you do these four
things
get the bishop g are three things rather
bishop to g2
knight to e2 castles now against any
move you should be playing e4
you should just be pushing e4
sacrificing that g
pawn don't waste your time with anything
else play e4
break in the center and then activate
your pieces that
is the idea for white in this case
sacrifice that g-pawn that g pawn is
meaningless
roll forward in the center and crush
your opponent
by the way i have actually had this
position over the board
i had this against one player who is
actually in the united states
chess championships currently and his
name is darrow
sweets and in that game i got a little
bit fancy and i played this move g5
thinking that i would just be better
after something like this
but again it was sort of just a waste of
time to uh to play this move g5 i should
just be playing
e4 immediately this is the best line for
white and i do believe it leads to a
very nice advantage
for white once again so there was one
more
question way back here i believe which
was something like
bishop takes g4 knight e4 is white just
checkmated here
well okay i can castle here so maybe the
question was
way back here bishop takes g4 knight e4
that's why checkmated i mean i can go
bishop g2 i can also just play something
like knight g3 here
a piece is a piece as as i like to
sometimes say
so not going to get checkmated right off
the bat and
yeah white white is doing quite quite
well with an extra piece here
so any questions on this c4 idea before
i move on
uh varun in the chat is
apparently very familiar with this game
and he says in the final position
there's a reason why
you put the queen on f4 and not some
other square
uh and yeah okay it's it's to defend the
e5 pawn
uh rook a1 is sort of the only idea
for black and then if your queen is on
f2 or f3
queen takes e5 is is going to be a check
here so i imagine this was the point
this was the point of playing queen f4
over queen f2
alright this would be slightly awkward
but yeah nice win by vidit
why does black play knight c1 again uh
well if white actually doesn't play
knight c1 let's say they
just play something like a5 pushing
forward it's very very useful for white
to
to actually preserve this bishop this
bishop is sort of a monster
on the wide open board as the center is
is opening up
and by the way bishop g5 this is just
this is
dead even though a move like bishop e3
here i think
okay well maybe not with this pawn
hanging but let's say something like
this
bishop e3 now once again
um white is sort of just crushing with
with the dark squared bishop
partly because it has good attacking
prospects also partly because
black's play really revolves around this
move b4
and a huge part of b4 is that it weakens
the dark squares
in white's center and with this bishop
to defend them then white is is just
always going to be better so
black should always always always play
knight takes c1 uh
specifically in this case because bishop
g5 is is very very strong
but even if bishop g5 didn't didn't
exist for example knight takes g4 would
be a better move that i'm not suggesting
even bishop f4 just bishop f4 here and i
think white is
white is doing quite well this bishop is
just too important
um yeah i i went over that briefly
briefly
uh pip and chuck went over that briefly
one more time for pip and chuck in the
chat
if g4 um takes
takes here you can go bishop g2
with knight g3 in response to queen h4
you can go knight g3 immediately
um queen h4 might be the best try here
but like everything everything is
winning queen f3 bishop g2
it's it's all winning uh a piece is just
too much a piece is just too much
no time
it seems like white's going to get mated
by bishop on g7
b7 no i don't know what to tell you no
okay
with the c5 variation yeah i wanted to
go over this variation first
just to recap for everybody because this
is the variation that i actually face
the most often
online and over the board against class
level players which is
what i assume many of you are this by
far
is the most common variation that i face
like i said
at the top level it's not the most
common because i think it just leads to
advantages
for white but um class level
i'm facing this the most often and i
think it's also very very easy to pick
up and learn
okay there is actually one more idea in
this opening aside from
c4 in the mainline stuff that we're
looking at with castles
and it's actually the most interesting
idea for black in my opinion
and that is the idea of queen to c7 a
very counter-intuitive move
but it's a very very tricky move i was
sort of taken aback
at how tricky the queen c7 lines
actually were i was vaguely aware that
this move existed before prepping for
this lecture i
have very very rarely faced it i think
maybe once or twice even like online
i've run across this queen c7 move but
it does have a little bit of venom
and this move is actually so so rare
that nobody at the top level is really
playing it
and the actual best game that i could
find i'm going to flip to now it was
between these two nobodies they're like
2 300 feet a
they just have a random game in the
database but my oh my
they played they like they must have
super prepped for this game because they
were both playing the absolute best
moves
on every turn so i wanted to give them a
shout out no idea who these people are
gabriel molina and al girdas rauduve
but well done they played a really good
game of chess so
let's jump into it here and explore what
this queen c7 move is all about
c4 e6 knight c3 bishop b4
f3 d5 a3 takes takes
c5 takes takes in this case e3
queen c7 and what is the point well the
point is if white plays a little bit
naively with bishop d3
you're running into c takes d4 c takes
d4
and queen c3 check and uh oh bishop d2
hangs the bishop queen d2 of course
hangs hangs the rook and white can't
save everything
so queen c7 is a very very clever way to
prevent white's optimal setup
and it turns out that i think queen c7
is quite simply a
better version of the c4 line now why do
i say that
well as i mentioned in the c4 line
a huge reason why g4 is so good for
white
is because black has closed down the
center with the move c4
and in fact this move queen c7 has the
same idea
of preventing bishop d3 as c4 does
however black has left the option open
to occasionally
open the center still and so i do think
this is just a better version for it
because the best ideas i could find for
white are the same ideas as in the c4
line
and that is you go g4 and
develop in this manner
so i want to talk about a few different
move orders here before we get into
the actual game variation so i very
quickly played knight c6 which is a fine
move
for black however it does sort of
alleviate the pressure
on c3 here so what if black just castles
directly well again this move g4 i think
is the right idea
but then black has an interesting idea
to just go go rookie eight
so chat i'll be impressed if you guys
can can find the best move
for white in in this case castles and
rookie eight and i actually think this
is
potentially the most accurate move order
by black this is the way to apply the
most pressure here
so yes for those just joining i'm
planning to do
uh pretty much every relevant variation
in the f3 nimzo
i wanted to start with this because
these are these are the very very fun
lines
for whites and they're actually the
lines that i'm i'm getting the most
often and yeah
the chatroom has it it's it's king f2
king f2 is sort of the
the shocker here um but yes
king f2 in a sense is just as safe as
castling
after the move f the moves f3 and uh and
g4
so what's the point of of king f2 well
for one we're stepping off of this queen
c3 idea
for two we're stepping off of the e file
and
number three the downside to bishop g2
is we really would very much rather have
this bishop on d3 this bishop is just so
good on d3 right and bringing it to g2
is is very much a concession whereas if
we can play king f2
then after knight c6 finally black
should be developing this piece there's
nothing else really to do
now we can go knight f4 and in short
order
this bishop is going to be able to
develop out to uh
to its best square on d3
now actually the lines here get pretty
interesting because with knight f4
white is very very much making a threat
and this
position has actually occurred six times
over the board in the lead chest
database that i'm using
and in all six games black played 97 if
you go
sort of naively with knight a5 lookout
knight ace
or g5 knight takes d5 is winning a very
very important
central pawn so 97 almost required
by black and then white can actually
immediately
start launching a king side attack with
the move h4
and these lines turn out to be a lot of
fun and they also turn out to be pretty
good for white
so what more can you ask for black's
best move here
is knight g6 that's not an f4 is just
too powerful you have to get rid of it
um otherwise um
you know black is white is just going to
develop very naturally with bishop d3
and continue pushing on the king's side
so knight g6 is the best idea
and then white can actually go for a
slightly weird structure with
h5 and taking with the e pawn now queen
a5
is applying pressure here and here
i was absolutely stunned we are in the
game continuation now
by the way it transposed eventually so
let me
flip on over to the the really chest
line or actually no this this is the
really chess line
okay uh sometimes leeches studies do the
strange thing where they swap where the
variations are
but we are in the game continuation and
like i said i think this is the best
that both sides can do so far i think
this is essentially the
the perfect main line by these two
random players which is pretty
incredible
and then white plays a move that is
absolutely stunning
that you know like computers they don't
really even see it on
on lower depths but when you go through
the variations
it turns out to just be really good for
white so white has
you know a very solid advantage here uh
pretty much any
reasonable move is is close to plus one
at least plus point seven
but the absolute best move which
stockfish doesn't immediately find
is the move played in the game which is
the move a4 and like i would never
like i mean what is a4 like what like
what
i mean how do like what gabriel what are
you doing gabriel you play
what is that what is a4 but it's the
best move
for uh for white why is it the best move
for white well as we can see in the game
the idea is after queen takes c3 rook a3
is now uh actively defending laterally
along the third rank an idea that we've
seen with rook a2
but is now sort of perfected with rook
a3
and the point here is that if black
starts
pawn hunting these pawns are never going
to survive
and white is sort of just dominating
with the two bishops in a wide open
position
white is very much better in this
position these bishops are going to
control the entire board
and in the game black tried to be more
active and sacrificed to piece on g4
queen c3 still rook a3 now knight g4
check
is good if you take this guy then queen
takes c1 as a problem
but the very accurate king g1 by gabriel
in this case
was enough to win the game black did
cash in on d4
but now rick h to h3 and white not only
has two very powerful bishops
but black is left with only one knight
as opposed to white's two bishops and
white is
just pretty close to winning in in this
position at least
should be very very happy with with the
game that that you got from the opening
up a full piece um
gabriel may have been a little naughty
with a hidden engine i think that the
guy probably just prepped this variation
very very well
um you know they both have uh
pretty similar spanish sounding names in
my opinion i'm no expert on these things
maybe i'm
saying something something awful and
neither player is spanish
but i would sort of assume what happened
is these two players sort of knew each
other that they knew what they played
and when you get a situation like that
that's when you get some crazy opening
prep
because it's like all right i mean i
know the guy's playing queen c7 here
let me let me book up on it i know i'm
gonna play him in this tournament and
and that's how you get something like
this happening
um so okay that is gonna do it for the
lecture tonight any questions
on this uh this line of the f3 nymph so
i'm going to call
it the e takes d5 line uh after of
course
this move here we take on c3 and e takes
d5
this is as i said not a very common
variation
at the top level but it is super common
it is the most common variation against
the f3 nimzo
at the amateur level um so any questions
on this
because this is the line you guys are
actually going to be facing the most
often uh i'm
fairly confident this is the stuff that
you're going to be running into
almost 50 percent of the games in the f3
nimso
so any questions
and yeah thank you for the feedback on
on chesapeal once again
i'm sort of considering making a
chessable course i'm pretty sure it
would be free
uh for you guys but it would be sort of
a lot of work
so let me know if there's enough
interest for that until then i am going
to be
keeping all of these uh lines all the
variations in this lead chest study that
you can
access through through the description
of the video there
uh so check that out if if you want a a
copy of the lines
and yeah let me know what you think do
you like the f3 nimso as much as i do
were those four wins at the beginning
overboard did you not need to see all of
them i just wanted to convince you guys
this opening is good you get free wins
what's better than free wins
there's nothing better than winning a
chess game without having to think at
all all right and that's what this will
do for you
okay it's all of the chess all of the
winning none of the thinking
that's great that's the best okay
that is actually going to do it for the
lecture though tonight if you're
watching live please head over to the
twitch channel we're going to be
continuing with tactics time if you're
watching the youtube version thank you
so much for joining me as always my name
is caleb denby
and i will see you next time
you